David should Al Franken really have
resigned from the Senate given what has
happened since and the gross misconduct
that Republicans have both participated
in and excused from people at all levels
of government up to and including serial
assaulter Donald J Trump listen this
this is a complicated thing to talk
about because anytime you say someone
who resigned for some kind of misconduct
shouldn't have done it it's implied that
you are minimizing or dismissing the
importance or the severity of what they
did and Al Franken participated in some
tasteless pictures where he I'm going
from memory had his hands over the
breast area above I think a flak jacket
of a journalist who I think was sleeping
and was wearing a flak jacket during
some kind of trip I I don't I don't
remember exactly what the circumstances
were but I think that the left needs to
be comfortable in these situations as
we've tried to do on the show
distinguishing between Al Franken taking
part in a tasteless picture someone
being accused of making their date
uncomfortable when they were at the
person's apartment I think that that was
the case with Aziz Ansari is that I hope
I'm remembering correctly that is
different from a consensual workplace
romance that violates the rules of the
workplace right so that's example of the
example out of California 25th that has
now led to Christie Smith and Genki Gore
in the special election
Katie hills seat to being accused of
raping someone at the other end of the
spectrum forcible rape it's okay to say
that these things are different and
you're not excusing any of them but this
is where you really see a difference
between Republicans and Democrats and I
I have no interest in defending or
attacking anyone beyond what they
deserve on many issues Democrats and
Republicans are almost or equally
corrupt and wrong on this particular
issue Republicans had a guy accused by a
dozen women of sexual assault and they
elected him president Democrats had Al
Franken accused of participating in an
inappropriate picture and they demanded
his resignation so my answer is I think
the mistake was for Democrats to demand
Frank and resigned so quickly and I know
that in part they did it because they
wanted to appear as though we don't care
what party the person is in there was a
lot of me to stuff happening at the time
Trump stuff etc etc they wanted to
appear fair and balanced for lack of a
better term but they sort of shot
themselves in the foot because once they
called for Franken to resign Franken
basically has to resign and now in
retrospect I get one or two emails a
week where people say David the
Democrats went too far Al Franken
shouldn't have resigned and that is that
he was actually a good senator who was
doing very very good things I understand
it once the calls for his resignation
came I get why he did it I don't think
he had a choice at that point but I
think the mistake was to call for him to
resign so quickly
I'm not saying maybe eventually that
wouldn't have been what they work out
anyway
but I think it happened reflexively and
it happened too soon you know I'm
reminded of Anthony Weiner when Anthony
Weiner was caught sexting some underage
girl there were no Democrats defending
Anthony Weiner and and rightly so
because there was no defense of that and
on this issue Republicans will continue
defending their sexist altars and child
molesters in the entire thing Democrats
do not sometimes to a fault and that's
where I end up on it